Boomers [__] on gen Z when they're
the ones who created them do you know
that 50 years ago there wouldn't be a
single parent that went to a school and
fought for a kid to get a better grade
on their report card and now that is
common people are like it's social
media's fault no it's not it's parenting
in the modern world it's now about being
your friend's kid not their parent we're
not calling our kids out on their
[__] you can't create fake
environments we've created an entire
generation of zoo animals everything's
nice and Daisy the problem is they turn
22 and they have to live in the real
world and then and zebra that grew up in
the Bronx Zoo goes into the wild dies
within three seconds
lion bites his [__] head off